[Music]  you  she's competitive oh not so much I am  really competitive it's sad I'm pretty  competitive when it came back it was the  video game okay  video game for games when I was a kid  maybe but not anymore I hate to lose mmm  in any situation  I get very competitive I have no idea  what I'm being  like weird like the County Fair yeah you  see when there's like cardboard cutouts  you put your faces through yeah I feel  good dick useless honestly can i press  this button and it just kind of tastes  Oh  sorry  there we go you got me back I don't  think anything where you end up with the  mixture of snot and whipped cream is fun  this would be a lot more fun if we were  drunk and if the hand actually like  smacked you and I just you know I mean  just as cool and all yeah and funny I  feel like this game is fun if you're  willing to allow your kids to be messy  you're similar but anyway all right you  are a vengeful rich  [Music]